all right before we dive into this
episode the minimalist want to help you
declutter your glowing screen so head on
over to the minimalists comm slash
wallpapers to download any of our free
minimalist wallpapers including our love
people use things wallpaper for your
smartphone or computer enjoy bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
Ryan Nicodemus is out on vacation today
so I found another person named Ryan and
well Ryan holidays here is the author of
the brand new book stillness is the key
Ryan thank you for being here today yeah
thanks for having me today we're gonna
talk about stillness we're gonna talk
about quietude we're gonna talk about
combating distractions and we're gonna
talk about slowing down with today's
guest and our first question is from
Alex in North Dakota hey guys my name is
Alex and I'm from Minot North Dakota I
am graduating from college in about six
months and ultimately plan to continue
my education in a more meaningful way
once I'm done my goal essentially is to
learn a new skill either physically or
intellectually every six months or so
and I guess my main question for this
would be what are some of the most vital
or salient skills either physically or
mentally that someone living a more
Purpose Driven or intentional life
should strive for so Ryan skills you
have to build up some skills some new
skills every six months I think this is
a meaningful pursuit what uh what advice
do you have for Alex yeah I mean I do
like this idea I think there is you know
the the more you expose yourself to
stuff that you don't know how to do it's
sort of naturally humbling and naturally
kind of keeps you hungry like it's very
easy you know you talk about sort of
like having an intentional life sort of
shaping your life but the and I try to
do that too but the downside is you can
end up like only doing stuff you really
like or only stuff you're really good at
all the time you know what I mean
because you eliminated all the stuff you
don't like doing which is great like you
don't like scheduling okay get an
assistant maybe that's not something you
need to be good at but what you're doing
is you're kind of like softening your
because like your you're never
struggling or never challenged you know
you know grad school versus kindergarten
kindergarten everything is like
brand-new and like everything is
difficult even though you're not really
doing anything difficult but because
it's new it is difficult whereas grad
school it's it's these incremental
improvements I think there's there's
something to be said for both yeah but I
think what you're telling Alex here is
you know put yourself in more sort of
kindergarten like situations where it's
new to you yeah yeah and and I mean look
this is easier to do like if you know
what your main thing is like it's like
okay I'm a writer and then I can go
learn totally irrelevant skills that are
challenging and interesting that make me
better but they're not really designed
to help that there are like hobbies like
one of my favorite books is this book by
Winston Churchill and it's called
painting as a pastime so you wouldn't
think that basically the leader of the
free world would this guy who's sort of
probably the most ambitious man of his
age had an almost inhuman work schedule
and yeah what do you what he what he
liked to do in his spare time was paint
right and he wrote this book about about
basically the power of hobbies and he
was saying that like the most important
thing that at like a public person or
you know a powerful person needs to do
is he says you need to have one or two
or maybe even three like really good
hobbies and so for Winston Churchill the
hobbies were painting which he learns
sort of right after the First World War
he basically bungled a bunch of stuff
and he's sort of thrown out of public
life and he turns to painting and then
later he turns to bricklaying he learns
how to lay bricks he has this estate in
the English countryside and when he's
writing this book it's called the world
crisis he spends most of that there's
this awesome letter he writes and he's
like you know I've been writing 2,000
words and laying 200 bricks a day and
and so it's it was this idea of having
something totally the opposite of his
profession that was rigorous and hard
but forced him very much outside of his
comfort zone and forced it like you know
his his daughter would help him lay the
bricks and he would he would have to go
to a pretty place to paint a painting
right and then even within painting
you know Churchill would would talk
about how how he would try to get better
at painting right so he'd go like okay I
learned how to paint he's like now I
want to go to a museum really take
everything in and see if I can't repaint
a painting that I saw the next day right
or he'd say like I want to try to paint
something from memory so even within
painting he would set out to like add
skills to his sort of quiver and so III
just think maybe maybe this isn't what
the question is really about but the
idea of like if you find your main thing
and then you can be like these are all
these seemingly irrelevant side things
but are actually sort of giving you rest
and and and giving you some sort of
peace and quiet that help you be better
at that main thing we're gonna be
talking quite a bit about your your new
book today this is sort of I guess this
completes a trilogy for you in a way
right so so the first two books egos the
enemy and obstacle is the way and this
is stillness is the key I think one of
the things you're talking about here
whether it's brick laying or painting it
is reclaiming this sort of stillness
yeah yeah and I didn't mean to just like
direct this question back to my book
it's just something I think about like
how do you have like like in my routine
on a daily basis it's like I basically
work the first half of the day and then
the second half of the day I try to do
like exercise or I try to do something
that's very much the opposite of my main
thing because it back it balances it out
but then it also gives me a way to sort
of like I guess don't just think about
as like oh I'm acquiring skills think
about it as like I'm acquiring balance
or that I'm taking like let's say I have
a fresh grade in day writing but it's
I've never really had a frustrating day
swimming or like I've never had a
frustrating run like or a frustrating
day lifting weights like it's so much
easier to win over here and so if the
the hobby or the skill of the thing
they're spending time on it's just it's
just much more the success in it is much
more inner control and so it's I think
important to have that like it would be
good if for the president not I'm not
talking about any current present but
like it's good for a president to have
some physical activity that they like
the
they blow off steam doing or you know
that they have like quiet time to
themself like we need to have that in
our life so don't just think like oh I'm
figuring out this skill so like I'm
adding it now I'm learning finance and
now I'm learning this like it doesn't
they don't have to be professional
skills they can be like I learned how to
knit you know like you'd be totally
impractical and of no real value but
it's the process of doing it that is the
beneficial thing but the knitting or the
swimming can also become frustrating if
you're doing at a professional level if
your profession or professional knitter
then all of a sudden now you need to
find well I need to write in my off time
because because the burden of proof is
not that high for those those hobbies if
you're not trying to do a professor
professionally
yeah like Chris Bosh the the basketball
player like one season he taught himself
how to code in another season he taught
himself the guitar in the offseason so
these are not these are not in any way
beneficial skills on the basketball
court but the point was like he's not
gonna he's obviously training the
offseason but the point of the offseason
is to rest and to get some distance from
the game and to like let the body
recuperate but that doesn't mean you let
the mind atrophy you know what I mean so
so I think it's it's a just key that
you're finding things that are keeping
you sharp but ironically in keeping you
sharp you're you're also finding rest I
think what you'll find sometimes the
things you thought excited you or
interested you they may not actually
interest you once you dive into it yes
we often confuse excitement for passion
but you get excited about an idea I
really want to write this book but then
when the work actually comes down to
there's like ah maybe I'm not actually
excited about it that's true and also
though like you don't have to get good
at it do you know what I mean like you
can also just do it right you know like
like so I I've I run and I I ran in
middle school in high school and I hated
it and then I sort of rediscovered it
after college were in college and and so
I run almost every day I ran this
morning and so because people know they
run they go oh do you do marathons or
under this race I'm like I'm not trying
to get really good at it
like I'm just doing it like I'm pretty
naturally good at it and I do push
myself but like I don't need to turn
this into a competition
like I have a lot of competition in my
life and I have a lot of things that I'm
trying to like be world-class at I don't
need to be world-class in my hobby right
and I think that quite often that
contained the hobby as well if you're
just trying to - look if you're trying
to get it into a job yeah yeah well Alex
I'm gonna send you a copy of stillness
is the key I hope you get some value
from that our next question is from
Kerry and Anaheim California hi Josh and
Ryan my name is Kerry and I'm 20 and I'm
a stone student who's cultivating a
passion for television writing that I
plan on turning into a mission when I
graduate this semester I have an
internship but I absolutely love at a
company that I really enjoy working for
however the commute is awful I'm
commuting from Anaheim to Beverly Hills
twice a week last week I spent 10 hours
in the car on top of the full work days
which are for credit only they're not
paid I usually listen to music or this
podcast during the drive but I keep
finding myself really tired and
frustrated by the long hours in the car
do you have any advice on ways to make
my commute more pleasant or more
manageable without having to quit an
internship that I get a lot of value
from so Ryan the word that comes to mind
for me is peace yeah how could she make
her commute more peaceful in a way yeah
and that is a recurring theme throughout
stillness is the key you're talking
about stillness it's sort of finding
that inner peace and and by the way I
think we are we have more discrete bits
of input than ever before you write
about how the Stoics had this problem
where it's like put away your books and
go live life right but but also now it's
now we yearn for the books because we're
bombarded with social media we're
bombarded with the glowing screens we're
bombarded with just this the information
the the the cascade of information and
she's looking for peace and it seems a
bit quixotic to me to try to find peace
by like well I'm gonna use this commuter
I guess listen to more find more search
more how does she find peace I think you
can argue it either way I mean let the
irony is like she's 20 so when she
thirty let's say she achieves all the
dreams that she wants she has this
awesome career or maybe she's 40 and she
has a family she's gonna look back and
be like I can't believe I used to get 10
hours in the car by myself do you know
what I mean I was so wonderfully framing
it you know so so so it's it's like
don't don't necessarily see this as this
like huge inconvenience but try to see
it with try to flat it's like how we go
like we look back in our lives when we
see these like difficult periods we went
through but we're grateful for them it
would be wonderful if we could give
ourselves a little just oh I'm not
saying you can magically turn unpleasant
things into Pleasant things but if we
are gonna appreciate them a little bit
more in the future can't we give ourself
like even 10% of that now so just going
like I have this time and I'm not gonna
feel angry about it I'm not gonna try to
rush through it I'm just gonna be like
this is it
you know I think that's one way to start
it although I do I got this advice from
Robert Greene when I was about that age
I was his research assistant I had an
internship for someone sort of just like
she had and lots of you know long
commutes it was in Los Angeles and and
he just sort of gave me this advice he
was like he's like you there's two times
of time he said there's a lifetime and
dead time dead time is like you're in
the car and you're like I have an hour
to kill right a lifetime is like I have
an hour how am I gonna use this hour you
know or it's like hey I have three
months left on this internship I don't
really like it I want to do something
else like am I gonna quit am I gonna
complain am I gonna phone it in or I'm
gonna be like how can I use these three
months to some positive end and so I
like that she's listening to a podcast
or she's listening to music but you
could also say like this is how many
people would kill for an hour to
meditate you know and like I'm gonna
find this time to just have one hour
quiet myself like how can she use this
time I I have a commute some days and so
it's like that's when I make my phone
calls
yeah like that's what I call my parents
that's when I you know that's when I
catch up with people I haven't talked to
in a long time that's when I where I
just think about stuff that I'm working
on so it's this hour doesn't have to be
wasted and you don't have to find a way
to like rush through it you can go like
how can I use this to my advantage how
can I like really be present for it
and get a lot out of it and I think
peace ensues from that yeah I agree I'm
thinking about now the reframing I was
in the corporate world in a previous
life
I managed 150 retail stores which I know
is really ironic with the whole
minimalism thing but I think that led me
to this and nicodemus I worked at the
same telecom company and I had a lot of
commuting because I lived in Dayton I
worked in Cincinnati and so like I was
driving back and forth and I probably
spent I don't know 10 to 15 hours a week
in the car sometimes more than that and
at the time I I'd begrudge the fact that
I had to have so much of a commute but I
also realized that it was actually I'm
an extreme introvert yeah it was the
only time of my life that I had a loan
yeah yeah it was great for me in
retrospect and now anytime I go back to
Ohio it's like I have the most pleasant
memories of driving whereas before it's
it's because I assigned some sort of
negative connotation to it and I think
it is quite often as easy as
appreciating what is good from this
commute yeah maybe it does suck to drive
from Anaheim to Beverly Hills every day
but maybe it's also awesome you have the
opportunity to have that alone time
there every single day yeah and look
like we know like okay you make a
hundred dollars you have to pay a
certain amount of that in taxes right
like we know there's tax associated with
all good things right you make money pay
taxes one of the things that Stokes talk
about is just like paying the taxes of
life willingly and gladly almost right
so instead of being like oh it's April
15 that came about - right this huge
check to the government we should be
like no this is what I have to pay to
get what I got right and every year I
post this on social media and people get
very mad you know as like crazy
ridiculous trolls but it's just like
what you have a life-changing internship
that you get fulfillment out of that's
like getting you closer to where you
want to go the our drive is attacks yeah
you know like nothing is free like even
though you're working for free nothing
is free and so if you just go this is
the tax right like arguments are the
tacks of being married you know like
phone calls or the tax of
of work you know or whatever right
there's just taxes associated with all
the stuff that we have to do and the you
know most most taxes are progressive so
the more stuff that you get or do the
more taxes that come along with it yeah
and I guess any of those taxes are
things that may not be pleasant in the
moment but I like that idea of reframing
even the you know it's April 15th I'm
gonna write this check I can find a way
to make it more pleasant than it is even
if it isn't truly pleasant to me what
can you just get to neutral like why
don't we just start by like I'm gonna
get to neutral like I'm just not gonna
be resentful right of the fact that I
have to pay taxes because taxes are a
part of life and that's what I'm doing
you know I'm not saying you pay more tax
than you have to hate you know you're
not like I'm around up here you know or
whatever you get an accountant you have
you try to minimize the taxes you don't
need to pay but then when they're like
look here's the bill you write the check
isn't the carry I'm gonna send you a
copy of our book essential is a hundred
and fifty essays in there about what it
means to live an intentional life it's
twelve different areas and one of those
areas is mindfulness and so as you're on
the road and you're you're looking to be
a bit more mindful with your time I
think there are some tips and strategies
in our book essential if you like our
podcast you like the audiobook version
of that it's over six hours long or if
you want the book book or the eBook
version we're happy to send those to you
as well it's the whole week of commuting
almost that's right you know audio book
or at least it's listen to the
mindfulness chapter and maybe turn it
off that for that let's move on to our
lightning round now Ryan this is where
we typically answer questions from
social media we're at the minimalists on
Twitter Facebook and Instagram you're at
Ryan holiday and all the relevant social
media networks also Ryan holiday net I
believe is your website there's another
Ryan holiday he's like a Christian
musician or something so we had Sam
Harris on here and I guess there's a
musician who's sam Harris who has all
the handles and it's like I can only
imagine how frustrating that that must
be I have a like you know my email is
Ryan I was like Ryan dot holiday Gmail
is just like I got it when I was in high
school and that's I think and I was like
who's this guy that has like Ryan
holiday Gmail like how did he beat me to
this it took me like eight years
realize that I have that that the dot is
me that's that's true put dots between
every letter doesn't matter yes make its
way to you maybe bleep out his email
okay good luck
anyway the lightning round so what we do
we try to answer every question which is
a short shareable less 140 character
response okay we put the text to these
minimal Maxim's we call them their
little aphorisms truisms whatever we put
them in the show notes and if you don't
have anything pithy it's okay Shawn we
can just monitor on a bit Shawn
tweezers it out that's it in the show
notes makes actually really creating the
characters a nice I think we're good
also we collect them all in one place
now minimal Maxim's dot-com our first
question is from Lady Lizza
she says it seems like the world is
constantly sending messages to never
slow down and keep going no matter the
cost
how does one combat these messages I've
a pity answer for you so you tell me
what you think about this Ryan my pithy
tweetable answer is moving slowly down
the right path will get you there
quicker than sprinting behind the herds
racing in the wrong direction yeah
there's a Latin expression that then
gets Festina lente and just means make
haste slowly you know measure twice cut
once
you know the I think we think like oh
I've got to like pull an all-nighter
I've got to rush through this or I've
got to you know get it out fast and then
what we have trouble calculating is like
the costs of having to go back and do it
or fix it and that's certainly true in
my own life I'm always someone who sort
of speeds through things and then it's
like the problems that this creates
usually net out to just haven't got it
right the first time
I think busyness has become the sort of
status symbol of success and in fact we
we just mistake it for success because I
used to always say I'm busy you know
when I was in the corporate world
working 80 hours a week work to 362 days
a year
and I how's it going oh it's real busy
yeah but really what I was saying is my
life's out of control sure though for me
success is like how empty my calendar
because it means I'm doing [ __ ] that I
want to do that is pithy I really like
that alright next questions from Paulo
how do you balance your work life with
your family life when you're trying to
build a meaningful business and have to
work really hard
now Ryan you you have a kid is he - yeah
I have two kids oh okay yeah we called
also no kidding yeah yeah you're out
here I am on the the book grind and this
is part of the this is part of the tax
you have to pay if we're writing a book
is is we often mistake as as creatives
like I wrote the book and now I'm done
and yeah you're halfway done now yeah
yeah obviously I would try to tell
myself is what you get to do but you do
have to do it right because like if you
don't market it you don't get to do
another one
right there's no audience right so it it
is a balance I'm I once asked the this
NFL coach I was like you guys worked
these like insane hours you have a
family of kids like how do you do it and
he was like you have to find the moments
inside the moments and what he meant by
that is like so from the outside you
think like oh like this coach he worked
looking shows up at the facility at like
5:00 a.m. he works out and then he
doesn't he doesn't leave until like
10:00 or whatever right and then you
realize it's like oh okay actually like
he shows up at 5:00 but that's where he
works out like the gym is at the office
right so a normal person leaves it
leaves at the same time or they go to
the gym right like so that they're
putting that they built a facility that
allows them to do everything in one spot
but then also there's like families
there all the time
it's like integrated inside the thing so
they might be at the office from here to
here but they have a much more sort of
inclusive like immersive experience do
you know what I mean it's yeah like
they're not gone for 14 hours they show
up to this house full of strangers and
that's something I've tried to cultivate
in my life where it's like I'm working
from home so I'm upstairs but I'm coming
downstairs to get something to drink and
I'm spending 15 minutes with my kid you
know like so they're obviously there are
downsides to sort of switching between
tasks and we know like what studies show
about this but it's about finding so
you're working hard and you're really
dedicated to what you're doing but I
think you want to try to
be absentee you know like not be gone
you want to integrate these things yeah
I like that as opposed to trying to
balance you know all the spinning plates
where you you are you're to mix my
metaphors here you you you're
integrating instead of balancing quite
often and I think if you find ways to do
that at least in my life it's been a lot
more pleasant to - I don't believe in
work-life balance so much as I believe
in work-life integration where possible
now also realizing that you know maybe
whether it's Paulo or someone working in
a cubicle somewhere you don't always
have that opportunity you might be in a
season of your life where does require
balance yeah yeah yeah I mean look
there's a period for a chunk of my 20s
where I was very much out of balance
right because you had to be to sort of
make your bones and to get to a position
where you had more autonomy but allsey
the American Apparel days yeah and I
worked not far from here at a talent
agency in Hollywood for a while and it
was a research assistant for writer I
just did like a bunch of stuff all at
the same time and but that I didn't also
have a family you know like it the idea
was like this is that period I'm gonna
do all the things now but it's also
being like people it's also knowing that
your work you better be working towards
autonomy or you can get sort of trapped
you know what I'm saying
yeah yeah I I find that we mistake this
idea of job security I think job
security is the least secure thing
because at any moment the the telecom
that I worked for was eventually bought
by another telecom they closed all the
stores that I was no longer there
anymore but had I been there and my nice
secure job everyone
I can't believe you're leaving the the
healthcare and the security no I would
have been laid off just like everyone
else right and so so it's almost a
misnomer when we talk about security the
most secure thing is finding that I'll
tell on me that that you're I mean this
sounds like Paulo was actually working
toward that he's building his own
business that hurt the pity answer I
will give you Paulo as hard work isn't
the same thing as meaningful work yeah
and because I think quite often we
confuse the two if I'm working hard and
I mean yeah you can you can run around
in circles my daughter does this until
she gets dizzy yeah there's nothing
meaningful about that but she feels like
she's doing some
productive because she's running around
in circles but I think your point about
integration verse balance it's like okay
you know let's say it's some morning and
I've got a 12:00 p.m. flight and I've
also got an exercise it's like oh I'm
gonna put my son in the stroller and run
with him do you know what I mean so it's
like now I've taken two things I have to
do and combine them together and they're
enjoyable and it's it's integrated in
that way
I find that parenting doesn't often
feels less than meaningful and and what
I mean by that is part of parenting
isn't like trying to be dad of the year
every moment it is simply showing up and
in being present with the kid and I mean
I only only have one kid and I don't
always find that as meaningful as I'm
gonna sit down and be productive we're
gonna write 2,000 words today or
whatever like to me there's like some
product of that the the product of
parenting is is also there but it seems
far more nebulous in in the moment well
there's this interview I read with Jerry
Seinfeld once and he was like he's like
parents are always talking about having
the quality time with their kids and
he's like I don't know what that means
he's like he's like I like garbage time
with my kids she's like you know eating
cereal at like 11:00 p.m. when you
should be in bed or you know what I mean
like like did this idea that like
parenting or family time it has to be
just like special stuff like actually
this is a lot of pressure on like
long-distance relationships you're like
we didn't see each other on the week
during the week now we're here on the
weekend we have to do something big and
it's like you don't have to do anything
right and in fact that might actually be
putting additional like you've you're
out of step with each other and now
you're trying to do this complicated
dance where you you know you're cramming
in a trip on the weekend or you know
going out or seeing people and it's like
you could have just stayed at home on
the couch and you would have had much
more meaningful of an interaction so
that I think that's the other thing with
kids is like it's like oh I'm I'm I'm
I've been gone and I'm home and so it's
like I have to make up for this and it's
like no you just have to sit there while
they play with trains on the floor yeah
like that's
that's that's parenting absolutely and I
found one of the most meaningful things
we do almost every night is we you as a
family my wife and I and our
six-year-old daughter will just walk
around the block once yes and and it's
it's it's ritualized so we do it most
nights and and I find that that is far
more meaningful than like you know we
have to try to do the trampoline park
and we have to hit yeah those things are
fun and and there's there's a time for
those but if you work that into every
day if that was your daily expectation
you continue to up the threshold and at
some point you know we're like bungee
jumping every evening in order to just
yet to have fun and also like garbage
time is pretty much free you know I mean
like your walk is free right yeah like
so people are like oh you know like
privilege and but like the best things I
don't cost anything you know what I mean
like the walk is the special thing it's
not it the walk is probably has more of
an impact on your kid than like over a
long enough time line and like sending
them to an expensive private school or
something I would argue yeah and it's
funny like I will ask her about hey do
you remember the time we did blank and
it's always like some amazing thing when
she was two years old and she no don't
remember it at all yeah but she
remembers the the sort of
inconsequential and I think that's how
life is you know you never you know it's
not always the big moments that that you
in fact in the book you talk about lust
being a bit of a problem right because
we want these peak experiences whether
whether it is an orgasm or winning the
trophy for the the race or whatever it
is we're in wanderlust like I got to go
to Machu Picchu because I'll get a good
Instagram photo and then you know I'll
have crossed that off my bucket list and
yeah all the cool people I know I've
been there
yeah yeah well shopping you got some
pithy stuff there to tweeze out and it
looks like we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week how do I find
stillness in the middle of a crisis how
do I find peace in a toxic relationship
to which I'm legally bound how do I cut
out the brain noise to stay focused on
one project at a time how do I find
living in chaotic urban surroundings how
can I find peace
despite chronic pain and many more of
your questions
also we're gonna talk about Napoleon's
best email inbox tip that was fun
also we're gonna talk about some stoic
wisdom we're gonna talk about journaling
why I don't like journaling and Ryan
holiday convinces me that maybe I should
be journaling how successful people will
recharge in their downtime we're gonna
talk about silence we're gonna talk
about Tiger Woods's dreaded keyword
we're gonna talk about confidence versus
ego and we're gonna talk about the
difference between leisure and escapism
and if you want to hear all that you can
listen to this week's maximal episode
available exclusively on patreon that's
right your current list to our weekly
minimal episode but each week actually
know what let me let me skip the script
this week podcast John let me just say
this every week on patreon we do a
long-form podcast we call it a maximal
episode we just finished recording this
one with Ryan holiday I can tell you
this it's one of the most meaningful
conversations that I've ever had we
answered a bunch more questions we had a
really great conversation about
stillness about stoicism about all kinds
of stuff about silence being the not
it's not necessarily the absence of all
sound we talked about how certain
successful people a recharge in their
downtime we just we had a really
meaningful conversation we talked about
writing and tips for writing and
creativity Ryan holiday and I just
really hit it off on the maximal episode
I would encourage you to listen to that
you can listen to it in your regular
podcast app if you become a patreon
supporter also we're capping our patreon
supporter 6,000 people because we
decided that's enough so there are still
some spots left if you do want to be
part of the minimalist private podcast
it's a separate long-form podcast every
week where we really dive deep into your
questions we we get kind of personal on
that in ways that we don't talk about
things in public so if you're interested
in that and you want to go
a lot deeper with respect to minimalism
or stoicism or stillness or the topics
we tackle each week with our guests then
head on over to the minimalists comm
slash support you can become a supporter
there I know it's just a couple dollars
but that goes really far it allows us to
keep this podcast a hundred percent
advertisement free we think
advertisements suck we don't want to do
them on our podcast and so you those of
you who are our patreon supporters keep
this podcast alive and keep it 100
percent advertisement free find all the
details and all the good stuff over the
minimalists com a slash support and now
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners hello Josh and
Brian my name is Mandy bender I am
calling from Lincoln Nebraska I'm
calling today because I have a great
solution for what to do with an old
wedding dress especially if it's kind of
outdated and not likely to be worn again
the hospitals in my area have a
wonderful program that volunteers who
take old wedding dresses and make burial
grounds for infants I think this is a
great way to honor these children and
they know it is something the families
mourning the loss of a child will find
value in
hi this is Jesse Hazelwood in Austin
Texas and I was listening to the podcast
and a woman commented about what's next
I've decluttered and now what's next and
I think that I've experienced some of
the anxiety that I heard in her voice
about okay now now what and I think that
I personally still feel the need to veg
out and not work and but at the same
time I will go and check my email and
now that is a joy to me because I've
cleaned it out and the emails that I'm
getting are telling me that I've got a
new podcast or it's my favorite shopping
site I really like fashion in
researching fashion and but I get to sit
down and enjoy that and not worry about
oh this isn't clean my house is
cluttered and I need to get up and do
something and have that extra layer of
anxiety on top and then also clean my
guitar when I'm playing it I'm not
worried about all the things that I need
to do I can actually sit down and enjoy
doing the things that I want and finding
joy in my life all right so thanks again
to Ryan holiday for one of the most
meaningful conversations I've had on
this main podcast also on our patreon
podcast and man we just talked about so
much I want to encourage you to check
out his new book stillness is the key
it's out this week you can check it out
wherever you get books you can find him
at Ryan holiday on social media Ryan
holiday dotnet is his website and also
he has a great book but also a great
website email list it's the daily stoic
you just go to daily stoic calm or
follow at daily stoic on social media
you can find that there as well he's
creating something meaningful for the
world something I think you'll get a lot
of value from check out stillness is the
key his lettuce book and real quick for
right here right now here's one thing
that's going on in the life of the
minimalists do you know about our side
project it's called minimalism dot life
that's the website minimalism dot life
you over there you can find free
beautiful simple wallpapers for your
phone or for your computer you
find some beautiful journal articles and
there's also over something over there
called inside minimalism where you get
the best of minimalist design minimalist
travel and minimalist well-being we
partnered up with Carl and Alberto from
minimalism oh and five style to give you
the best of all-around minimalism
minimalist design travel and well-being
all in one place
head on over to minimalism dot life if
you want to learn more about that you
can also follow minimalism life on
social media if you're on Instagram the
most beautiful photos and quotes that
you'll find over there it's just at
minimalism life on Instagram or if
you're on Twitter it's just at
minimalism on Twitter if you have a
comment question or minimalism tip for
our podcast leave us a voicemail for 0 6
2 1 9 7 8 3 9 or send a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists com
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalists if you
want our show notes in your inbox sign
up for our email list over at the
minimalists com
you'll also receive our simple Sunday
emails every week just head on over to
the minimalist calm at the very top
there's no pop-up at or anything like
that we don't do that crazy stuff but
you can just enter your email address
there at the top well never ever send
you spam but we will send you our show
notes and are simple Sunday emails each
week never any advertisements or
anything like that for our added value
this week you know I've been
rediscovering my friend Andy Davis's
music lately he opened up for us when we
were on tour in 2014 at our Nashville
stop and we've become friends since and
he's one of my favorite musicians in the
world and since we've been talking about
chaos today the the sort of chaos of
everyday life let's listen to a song
that's about just that here's a song
called
solution to run from one of my favorite
musicians Andy Davis this is from his
2012 album heartbreak yellow and if you
live here today with just one message we
hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listen y'all we'll see you
next time minimus